das hätte uns manche spaltung auch dort
ersparen und deshalb wahrscheinlich dass
die neue regierung es jetzt hinbekommt
unseren wohlstand und unsere anliegen
des klimaschutzes interessanten dazu
fällt deswegen weil man da zu spät wahr
haben ja freiheit ist future gegründet
dasselbe wird häufig gesagt natürlich
von der afg frau klöckner würden sie
sagen ohne angela merkel gäbe ist die
afg heute nicht oder nicht mehr
das wäre zu viel der ehre für die
kfd also ich meine gucken sie doch mal
wie die afg damals entstanden ist es kam
ja mit der euro-frage wir wissen alle
erstmal was ein professor der dfb
gegründet hatte dann nachher ausgetreten
ist die ard ist ja entstanden haben sich
vorwiegend männer zusammengefunden die
sich
gegen
europas gewehrt haben die zurecht
sicherlich den einen oder anderen aspekt
auch hatten was die stabilität des euros
anbelangt und dann ist diese idee die
ursprünglich aus
rechte ins extreme lager jetzt dass
angela martini in die schuhe zu schieben
das hätte ich jetzt noch nicht sagte
merkel das heißt ja gar nicht in die
schuhe schieben haben gewählt sie glaube
ich ihnen sagen es ist alles ein anti
polit weil man könnte sagen ich brauche
ich auf den nicht mehr
kommen wird geschenkt also ich meine ich
verstehe sie also anhalt ist aber das
wird mir jetzt echt so einfach es gibt
und wie sich die franken haben
wahrscheinlich sie haben ständig
antipolitiker stimmung und auch helmut
kohl war auch eine eine person der in
gewissen phasen antihaltung auf sich
gezogen hat oder denken sie mal an das
thema damals das war vor meiner zeit
nato doppelbeschluss was meinen sie was
dann los weil gesellschaft oder die
debatte um atomkraft von der einen wie
von der anderen richtung also die frage
ist letztlich eine andere wie gehen wir
kommunikativ damit um wie erklären wir
politik also auf ihre frage diese den
peter altmaier auch gestellt wie er
finde ich sehr klug beantwortet hat
würde ich einen weiteren aspekt noch
hinzufügen
glaube ich müssen uns alle fragen ob wir
in der zeit in der wir uns befinden wo
wir in konkurrenz mit facebook mit
instagram twitter und vielen anderen
ja wandelnden auch sind haben wir als
politik genügend erklärt richtig erklärt
und die schritte auch übermittelt damit
gesellschaft auch beieinander bleibt
aber dass man haltung hat und dass man
eine meinung hat die niall gefällt das
glaube ich es klar dass in zeiten
letzter punkt der digitalen medien dass
ich da natürlich auch andere anti
parteien starker organisieren können was
meinen sie wenn es zu helmut kohls
zeiten wenn es zu willy brandts zeiten
twitter und facebook gegeben hätte was
denn da los gewesen wer also ich glaube
dann ist man auch ein bisschen schwer
bleiben in dieser ganzen frage aber und
das ist magna wäre einfach diskutieren
total fair würde ich sagen sofort
erhalten möchte von den diesel wissen
würden sie sagen ohne merkel selbst die
ard nicht oder wert zumindest heute
nicht in allen länderparlamenten
also ich kann mich sehr gut an die zeit
erinnern als ich mit helmut kohl und
volker rühe und anderen wahlkämpfe
gemacht habe wir haben wertkonservative
inhalte verbreitet über die heute kein
mensch mehr redet ich glaube schon wenn
man inhalte inhalte der partei aufgibt
und sie über bord wirft kann man anderen
nicht vorwerfen wir die sie aufheben ich
habe in den 90er jahren über
asylmissbrauch und ähnlichen dingen
vorträge gehalten das haben wir alle
gemacht der sinn hat sich bloß bei uns
geändert und ich glaube dass wenn man
unsere partei heute sieht in dem land in
dem ich sitze in dem die schlechte
übertragung stattfindet da ist meine
partei der ich 30 jahre angehört habe
bei zehn prozent das kann doch nicht
wahr sein das müssen wir doch auch
kritisch sehen wenn es keine bürgerliche
politik mehr gibt dann muss natürlich
derjenige der diese partei geführt hat
auch dafür verantwortung haben ich trage
angela merkel genauso am herzen wie sie
alle und wie wir alle und wer das nicht
tut der als blind und erkennt ihrer
verdienste nicht aber diese verdienste
mache uns doch nicht blöd und taub
natürlich muss ein neuer wind kommen
natürlich ist es auch ihrer politik zu
verdanken dass rechts von unserer
wertkonservativen partei eine andere
struktur entstand ist und ich befürchte
dass diese struktur sehr dauerhaft
entstanden ist und ich möchte ja nicht
mehr und nicht weniger dass wir uns
wieder auf diese werte besinnen ich habe
sehr gerne mit helmut kohl war kann aber
noch ganz kurzfristig mal das ist
hochinteressant und wir geben das gleich
weiter an harald mayer aber einmal dass
den punkt mit der afg glauben sie dass
die heute genauso stark wäre ohne merkel
wir uns allen sind halt diese rufe immer
merkel muss weg es war ja total
personalisierte also dass ich sagen das
ist ja entschuldigung sicher ein
typischer ruf aus dem osten deutschlands
im osten deutschland hat frau merkel
leider den größten widerstand warum
nicht weil die menschen im osten dorf
sind weil sondern weil wir die menschen
im osten nicht erreicht haben und
deshalb muss man sich um diese menschen
kümmern man muss diesen furchtbaren
umstand dass in sachsen in
mecklenburg-vorpommern sachsen-anhalt
die kfd eben staatstragende große
parteien geworden sind diesen
furchtbaren umstand muss man
selbstkritisch unserer parteiführung
auch an lassen da der partei der ich
lange angehört habe und ich glaube dass
angela merkel hier etwas unterlassen hat
etwas nicht so sehr betrachtet hat wenn
ich mir die mannschaft um sie rum
angucke jetzt will ich die beiden in der
sendung ausdrücklich ausnehmen da sind
so viele da ist soviel unterform artiger
durchschnitt da es sind so viele leute
dabei die ihre tochter arbeiten haben
schreiben lassen und dies einfach nicht
können okay sind bei unter format im
durchschnitt aus dem natürlich sie und
lassen es natürlich so dass das ist sehr
gut
bedanke mich dafür ja auch ein reißt ihn
immer geschätzt solchen kaiser
verantwortung getragen
cdu ursprungs position aufgegeben hat
muss man sich dann auch nicht wenn also
nein erstmal ist es so das ist ja
richtig ist dass angela merkel im
übrigen nicht nur sie ich habe das auch
erlebt in kleinerem umfang und andere
politiker von der afg von einer
lautstarken krawalligen minderheit
gehasst werden zum teil zum teil auch
unflätig beleidigt werden aber ich kann
mich an keinen bundeskanzler erinnern
der zum ende seiner amtszeit die
zustimmung von mehr als zwei drittel der
menschen in deutschland ist immer noch
hatte und auch während der amtszeit
hatte nicht commander nicht helmut
schmidt nicht helmut kohl und her und
das heißt auch dass angela merkel
offenbar im urteil der menschen gut
wegkommt es gibt dem punkt den disco zu
recht an spricht nämlich dass die cdu
gerade in einigen ostdeutschen ländern
aber auch natürlich in den alten
bundesländern
schwächer geworden ist in den letzten
jahren und dann glaube ich allerdings
auch dass das nicht nur von einer person
alleine abhängig ist wir haben 400.000
mitglieder wir haben ministerpräsidenten
oberbürgermeister bundesminister wir
alle sind gemeinsam dafür verantwortlich
und die dinge sind halt eben auch nicht
mehr so unkompliziert wie sie früher
waren als ich in den deutschen bundestag
gewählt wurde haben wir viele wähler
gesagt aber geld harald meyer die frauen
sollen doch nicht arbeiten sonst wird
die arbeitslosigkeit ja noch höher sie
sollen sich um ihre kinder also münzen
glück darüber heute sind wir darüber
hinweg ja und damit tut sich eine kleine
minderheit schwer aber die große
mehrheit findet das richtig und die
menschen empfinden auch dass sie heute
als mensch stärker ernst genommen werden
und nicht mit man ihnen nur sagt ihr
müsst ihr müsst geräuschen sondern es
geht eben auch darum dass man den
familien dass man den menschen die
möglichkeit zu privatem glück eröffnet
leider nur aus ihrer sicht und aus war
klöckner sicht wie diese große mehrheit
zur großen mehrheit im moment nicht mehr
cdu sondern die große mehrheit liebt
irgendwie schätzt frau merkel und
trotzdem wählt nur eine ganz kleine
mehrheit oder eine ganz kleine menge in
deutschland noch cdu wir wollen aber
noch mal über merkels führungsstil
hier sprechen in dieser runde und über
das was man an diskussionen zugelassen
hat dass man in der zeit immer wieder
gehört in der partei ja hier wird nicht
richtig diskutiert man kann ja meine
seine meinung nicht offen sagen und das
hat man auch in einem teil von
deutschland immer wieder gehört vogel
erlass das fokussierte sich dann auf
dieses wort alternativlos die
wahrnehmung von merkels politik dass das
alles alternativlos ist dass es nur
diesen einen weg geht ist das ein
bisschen ja die schuld sozusagen merkels
war das so dass man ja durch das viele
vermitteln durch die suche nach dem
kompromiss den eindruck hatte da gibt es
nur noch die eine gültige meinung
na ja das wäre es übertrieben ich finde
es wird dir auch angelastet dass eben
dass man kompromisse schließen
muss und dass sie das macht aber was ist
denn demokratie da geht es eben um
besprechen um verhandlungen und dann auf
einen punkt zu kommen mit wo man
vielleicht zugeständnisse machen muss es
ist halt so in einer demokratie kannst
du nie dann deinen willen 100 prozent
durchsetzen aber wenn sie von sich aus
sagt für mich ist das jetzt
alternativlos ja alles gibt
mit euch diskutiert und ich glaube so
ist dann muss man natürlich schon ein
standpunkt einnehmen und das andere ist
möchte ich noch mal herausfinden also
mit mit ostdeutschland oder den neuen
bundesländern ich finde es sehr traurig
dass es so ist aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen was jetzt passiert ist europa
wächst zusammen und wenn wir das nicht
hinkriegen dass wir in europa sind wie
jedes land mit mit individuell mit den
mitteln bräuchen wie wir dass wir alles
machen aber wir müssen europa sehen und
wenn wir das mich sehen und wenn man da
nur an sich arbeitet dann können wir es
ganz vergessen und ich glaube natürlich
wenn die menschen nicht mitgenommen
werden ich weiß nicht ob diese dieser
große hass der mir natürlich ein ganz
anderer weise aber viel viel weniger
natürlich aber mir auch hingegen schlägt
das ist mir in rees wie menschen dazu
kommen
nur weil man eine andere meinung hat ein
derartig zu beschimpfen
in der tat sich hier auch ein rätsel
frau glas kann man
es nicht sagen ach das ist eben die
politik von frau merkel und deswegen
sind die leute jetzt da zum teil so
ausgeflippt also ehrlich gesagt das ist
mir zu einfach